hello there today we'll look at infinity
former infinite memory transformer by
pedro enrique martens zita mourinho and
andre f t martens
on a high level this paper proposes a
transformer that can attend to unbounded
memory in the past it does so by
building up what it calls a long-term
memory which is a continuous
signal rather than a discrete signal as
most of the other transformers do it
uses continuous attention to do so and
that enables it essentially to
continuously compress the past into this
continuous long-term memory and then
attend to it as it predicts next tokens
it also introduces the concept of sticky
memories which essentially are
events in the past that are of
particular importance to the future so
by keeping those sticky memories
specifically around they increase
performance yet again so we'll go
through the paper what the model looks
like how it works and what it does in
the experimental results
ha caught you you wouldn't have guessed
it but this video is sponsored by
weights and biases if you're in the ml
space and you don't know about weights
and biases what are you doing please if
you track your experiments using a
spreadsheet a piece of paper tensorboard
weird folder names like i used to do
stop that use weights and biases it's
one line of code and you can log any of
your experiments to the cloud not just
metrics but models data sets output
images little videos anything you want
say hello to zurich
believe me when i started the phd i was
looking for something like weights and
biases and i tried every single thing
there is i tried every productivity tool
every note taking tool and i just
couldn't get anything to work for one
part because the features were just
lacking for the other part because i was
just too lazy and weights and biases
solves both of those problems it has all
the things that i need to track my
experiments collaborate with others and
so on but also it's just a single line
of code and everything else works
automatically it even boosts my
productivity because whenever i have
logged a model i can just call a
function to download that model from the
weights of ics website i don't need to
place it in a correct folder or keep
track of it myself it's just there on
top of that it relieves me from the
stress of writing stupid overleaf
reports because i can write a weights
and pisces report and share that with
the people that i want to show my work
to the weights and biases report is so
much more useful than a pdf it's
essentially a website but you don't need
to code any html or css or whatnot you
can include dynamic content you can
reference the runs you did you can pull
out data from the runs you can present
that in a neat fashion and it gets even
more easy you don't even need
and it gets even more simple you don't
need to even set up anything in fact
weights and biases runs in the cloud by
default you can host it on premise but
it really wants to live in the cloud
all you have is an api key you log in
and you're good to go so please check it
out uh accounts are completely free for
personal use i promise you will not be
disappointed give it a try and now let's
get into the video bye-bye
[Music]
cool so there are a couple of good
things and a couple of questionable
things about this paper also there are a
lot of engineering choices in this paper
which i don't necessarily want to go
into there are a lot of things that one
could do differently i feel which in
influences the
experimental results as well i guess but
we'll just take it for what it is
the other thing is that i believe this
should be called
not infinity former but inft former
that's actually how you find it on
uh if you google for this you have you
can enter inft former inft being of
course the um abbreviation in latex for
this symbol right here and i think you
know to make it more unique we should
just call this the entity former
all right so what does the inf deformer
propose
they say in the abstract right here that
transformers struggle when attending to
long context since the amount of
computation grows with the context
length and therefore cannot model
long-term memories effectively
so there are a number of things
hidden right here they say the amount of
computation grows with the context
length now for classic transformers it's
actually worse right the amount of
computation grows quadratically with the
context length but even for some of
these let's say linear transformers
the amount of computation still grows
linearly with the context length
so they they see even this as a problem
they say they cannot model long-term
memories effectively
now
they say several variations have been
proposed to alleviate this problem but
they all have a finite memory capacity
being forced to drop old information in
this paper we propose the inf deformer
which extends the vanilla transformer
with an unbounded long-term memory
by making use of a continuous space
attention mechanism to attend over the
long-term memory the entity former's
attention complexity becomes independent
of the context length now already
remember right here there is
rarely a free lunch i don't want to say
there is no free lunch because i've
definitely
eaten free lunches before but there is
rarely a free lunch in these kinds of
things if we have a finite computation
we cannot pack infinite information in
there so if we are attending to
unbounded long-term memory that means
something else will have to give
and of course the thing that gives here
is just the amount of information you
can retain now this can be a good thing
to trade off sort of boundedness in time
for boundedness in information
yet still you have to keep that in mind
as i said they also introduce this thing
called sticky memories
that keep important things around
now
as we go through this this gets it in my
mind at least this gets more and more
into just like a classic lstm model so
the classic lstm model of course takes
in some sort of a
a input then models a hidden state then
propagates that hidden state when it
inputs the next thing and so on and it
sort of has to
keep track of what's important in its
own hidden state as to decide what it
wants to remember what it doesn't want
to remember so as with the transformer
the lstm has in fact an unbounded memory
right it can remember com things for
arbitrarily long yet it only has finite
capacity to do so it needs to overwrite
some memory every now and then so this
is a bit how you can think of this model
is essentially
the same principle as an lstm trading
off unboundedness for finite
representation
space i'm not saying this is an lstm it
is a little bit different it might be a
smarter way to do unbounded computation
uh it might not be but in concept it is
the sim the the similar thing
okay
so what's up with this continuous
attention that they keep talking about
this is
in if in in essence quite a simple
concept namely if you have a sequence of
let's say tokens right and every token
has an embedding vector so every token
is associated with a vector
that is its embedding and this can be
the first layer but this can be also the
intermediate
the intermediate values of the
computation so from one layer to the
next you always in the transformer have
number of tokens of these embedding
vectors that travel through the model
they get transformed into
by the next layer into new embedding
vectors and so on and so on
now the init deformer what it does is it
takes this signal right here and
and changes that from a discrete signal
into a continuous signal so you would no
longer have dimensions that you know the
first the topmost dimension here the
first dimension of all these vectors
might be whatever four five nine
point one
three
uh that's no longer the case what you
would have is like a continuous signal
okay now how do you do that pretty
easily what the inf deformer does is it
takes each of these dimensions
separately okay each of these dimensions
it plots these points up on a sort of
continuous plane so
this
this here so this it labels it from zero
to one so you divide this interval into
i guess five different points because we
have five tokens for the first one you
label sorry about that you label with a
four where is a four
i suck at this
so here is a four so dot here then here
is a five i guess so
dot here
nine
point one
and three
like here okay so here's three
cool and then what it does is
it it calculates an interpolation so the
interpolation would be
this
approximately right so it calculates an
interpolation of these points and then
it simply stores that interpolation it
forgets about the embedding vectors
themselves and it simply stores that
signal
and that is its so-called long-term
memory simply this signal now you might
wonder why don't we just store the
embedding vectors right
instead of the signal and that is of
course a good question the goal is of
course that you can store the signal
more efficiently than the embedding
vectors so if we can describe this
signal here with less than five numbers
then we might be able to um
then we might be able to
save some space right like what like
this is reasonable this could be a
polynomial of degree three right if for
example
like
if i draw this you know this is
reasonably a polynomial of degree three
ergo we'd have to store like three
numbers maybe plus a by so four
um
but if we agree that we always store
polynomials of degree 3 then no matter
how many embedding vectors we have we're
always going to store the signal as
three numbers or four numbers right as a
constant amount of numbers and that is
essentially the trick right here on how
we get away from the sequence length we
simply commit to a representation a
fixed representation of a signal
and and then we interpolate the
embedding vectors using this fixed
representation now the fixed
representation here isn't a degree
polynomial but it is in fact a
series of radial basis functions
so we associate each point in time which
is the
the here the one the two the like the
the interval from zero to one
um we index this into a radial basis
function and radial basis functions are
nothing more than
so
this is one
this is one okay so these are these are
three essentially these are three radial
basis function
spaced out right here and how could we
represent the signal from up here
uh using that maybe we can say okay
that's plus
you know if here is one like that's
plus 4.5 of that
of of let's call that psi one
then minus you know it goes down
like minus
three
of psi two
and then it goes up again like plus
four of psi three maybe some sort of a
bias plus two
okay so four numbers three radial basis
functions
all right so these things here are
completely independent of the data
they're not learned they're simply fixed
once like this is going to be
the our basis for representing all of
the signals
and then the way we transform the
discrete signal into the continuous one
is we run a regression so the regression
you can run by solving this system right
here by figuring out what is the matrix
b
here
and that's a linear system what is the
matrix b how do i have to mix the radial
basis
functions here in order to match my
signal as closely as possible
the way they do it is they run a ridge
regression ridge regression is simply a
um
a regression with an l2 penalty i i
think
is that the case yes i think so so
run y is equal to
x times w so you're trying to find w
like it's x times w
you're trying to find that so your loss
is going to be
the distance of these things
squared and then you have some sort of
regularization constant
and
on the l2 norm of the weights
so you solve this there's a closed form
solution this is the closed form
solution for ridge regression with f
being the matrix containing these basis
vectors this one right here
and there you get your b matrix so you
transform x which is
dependent on the length of your sequence
right into b
which is only of the length of how many
basis vectors you decide to have in this
case three or three plus one if we want
to bias again
all right so and that's how you have a
continuous signal you might already
hear you might already say wait isn't
this just a special case of a system
that simply compresses a sequence into a
variable length sequence into a fixed
length sequence like isn't this just a
way to embed
like a continuous
uh like an unbounded sequence
and i'd say yes absolutely
that's the first thing the second thing
is is certainly the whole procedure is
certainly not independent of length as
this system right here
is absolutely dependent on the length of
your signal and you can also see that
the longer your sequence gets the more
mistakes you'll actually make in
representing it because you only
represent it using the same basis vector
so here is where the trade-offs happen
by going from
length l to length i believe they call
it n the length here of the number of
basis vectors is n
so that's the first thing here's where
the trade-off happens the second thing
which
really
kind of interests me and here you see
this again right
so by the way this then they consider
their their memory right so you can
technically do this with all of the past
right you take all of the past you
remember the vectors right here and then
you interpolate
or what you can do is
you can
what they call
you know if you really go to unbounded
memory you take the past you take the
current sequence you can do what you can
do is you can contract the past which
means you can interpolate the
interpolation so you can sample it in a
more coarse grained fashion at
than the
you can sample it in a more coarse
grained fashion than you originally
produced it
which leads to samples like here and
then you concatenate with the new signal
and then you simply interpolate again
into the whole signal so you can see the
more distant past is now compressed to
that and the more recent past is
appended to that and of course in the
next step you'll contract this whole
thing
to a shorter sequence and append the
more recent thing right here and
interpolate again
how ex this is conceptually no different
from an lstm it brings about the same
problems as an lstm namely more recent
things are more likely to be in memory
than way past things and so on
um
so calling this you know being able to
attend to unbounded uh
unbounded memory and so on
is a
like it's a bit shady
like that just that's just my opinion
you have to be aware of the trade-offs
second of all second
is
the fact that
in order for this to work
right and we haven't even gotten to the
attention part yet we're just
representing our signal as a as a
continuous signal in order for this to
work you're counting on the fact that
there is some kind of a regularity like
here i've drawn these points
specifically such that i could draw a
neat line through them yet there is
absolutely no reason why
the
embeddings of the continuous you know
next to each other tokens should be in
any way continuous such that you can
interpolate it right you count on the
fact that you can compress the signal
because the signal like the samples go
like
right then you're like whoa i can i can
represent this by one line right one
radial basis function goes through all
of them cool
uh but there is no reason why this
should be like the signal could be like
completely
completely random in terms of
what the the real floating point numbers
are in the individual dimensions um yeah
they mitigate this a little bit by
smoothing the signal first before they
uh before they interpolate it but
in my mind that
kind of only makes it less accurate it
doesn't make the problem go away it just
makes it sort of less accurate because
if there is an actual value to having a
pattern like this if that's actually an
important
um an important pattern then neither
interpolating it
very coarsely with only a few basis
functions nor first smoothing it
will
will necessarily help
so
you know
i just from a principled standpoint i am
skeptical that
this is the case that signals
that these signals here are necessarily
such that they are easily interpolatable
but of course i might be wrong
so
you know that
that's it i might be wrong right
okay
so what do we do with it
all right let's say we have the past
in this long-term memory right this is
all of the past we've interpolated it
into this fixed
um long-term memory this continuous
signal that we represent as a
superposition of a fixed set of basis
functions we have our short term memory
here which is simply whatever we would
put anyway into the context of the
transformer right and then we have our
sequence that we actually want to deal
with
so the attention within
the
discrete part of the transformer is as
you know it this is self-attention a
training i guess masked self-attention
for certain tasks this is as you know it
the question is how do we make use of
this long-term memory right here
and
here is how we do it so for each
location in
where we want some sort of a prediction
right we produce a query as you know
if in a transformer layer every single
token produces to go from one layer to
the next produces a query vector the
query vectors tell what this token wants
to know about the sequence in the last
layer
now every
token also emits a key and a value
vector so key and value key and value
and so on
i'm only drawing the keys and then this
is routed by inner product
now the query of course we can keep the
query simply tells what does this token
want to know so the query is also taken
to go to the long-term memory
right so the query vector of each
discrete token now goes to the long-term
memory down here
and
we have to find a way to ask the
long-term memory something
according to this query so how do we do
it what we need is we need some sort of
a notion of a key and a value for this
long-term memory
and
here's how we compute it remember we
have it's not the continuous signal is
described by this matrix b right here
so if the continuous signal is described
by the matrix b then of course we can
compute
keys and values from b these w
matrices right here are learned
parameters
that take
b and make it into keys and values
now
the keys and the values are of different
length there are sequences they're
discrete sequences right they're of
different length than the length of the
sequence we're dealing with but that
doesn't matter nothing in a transformer
actually specifies that the next layer
always have to it has to have the same
length of sequence so what you can
imagine the way you can imagine this is
from the long-term memory essentially
what we're doing
is we're building
another sequence it's not as long
as the sequence that generated the
long-term memory but essentially we're
building another sequence of tokens they
are you know not necessarily
corresponding
to individual tokens in the inputs
they're corresponding to
how the thing is constructed but
nevertheless and from those we can
certainly generate keys and values as we
do regularly okay
so we essentially compress the past into
this pseudo sequence of fixed length
via a continuous representation
and then we just use attention again to
map
the keys here with the queries
now when it comes to actually computing
the thing
it's not it's not as easy
so this is in concept but when it comes
to actually computing the thing what we
want to do is we don't want to really
abstract this into series we would like
to use continuous attention so
continuous attention essentially means
that
our
attention doesn't go directly to one
particular token so it's not like we
know this token and this token and this
token but since we have a continuous
signal our attention should be something
more like well i want to attend to this
part of the sequence
and we model that as a probability
density over the sequence specifically
we restrict ourselves to a gaussian
so
what i can say is i can
my query
the interactions between the queries and
the keys will give me a gaussian
where i say i would like to attend to
this particular part of the sequence
right this is where in the past i want
to attend and this is how broadly let's
say i want to attend
you know how how many how much of the
surrounding i want to consider so this
this ultimately defines a gaussian like
where it is
and how
how far the gaussian is spread
right so i can attend to per
per query per token per head i can
attend to one location in the past and
its surrounding and the width i can also
specify
and this is also learned so as i
understand it these fine transformations
right here are also learned
transformations maybe i'm wrong in that
it just says a fine
um
but
yeah and then the sigmoid and the soft
plus are just regular functions but you
can see right here this is essentially
um as you are used to multiplying keys
and queries but then instead of
attending to the tokens themselves
because we don't have tokens right we we
specify a gaussian to attend over the
continuous signal
and ultimately we can
integrate essentially we can integrate
the two things so we can integrate the
values that we obtain
from
the
from the sequence
this these values we integrate them
according to the probability
distribution that we get and that's
going to be our output values
so these here
are going to be our output values
now once we have the output values from
the long term memory we add them to the
output values that we get from the
short-term memory and the sequence
itself add them together i think they go
through another affine transformation
after that and there is your
output and the output is going to be one
output per token in the sequence that
you're interested in
okay so
i know this was fairly lengthy but to
recap
we take the past
we do
we do a regression a ridge regression in
order to determine the coefficients to
represent the past as a continuous
signal with respect to a fixed set of
radial basis functions this gives us a
fixed size representation independent of
how long the past is
then the way we use the past is
we take the queries that come from the
attention mechanism
we
transform
the
representation of the past which is this
b matrix right here
into keys and values
we take the inner product between the
queries and the keys and this determines
a gaussian window for us where in the
past we want to attend to
we integrate the values from that region
according to the gaussian
and that's going to be our output signal
from the long-term memory this gets
added to the output signal of the
regular tension mechanism and that gives
us the output signal as a whole
okay this is essentially essentially it
and
if we do this one after another right we
could simply always go to the past and
compress it but we can also do this
trick that i mentioned before
this unbounded memory trick where you
always take the signal from the past you
compress it essentially by subsampling
it you concatenate the new signal and
then you interpolate again
and on top of this they introduce these
sticky memories and the sticky memories
simply say
look here
the points that i have sampled the
points that i have sampled this past
signal on here
i simply well don't believe my drawing
but i simply did that uniformly i sample
this uniformly
that kind of gives me a good sampling
of the
of the signal right i can also sample
this differently right i can over sample
certain regions and under sample certain
regions so here they say why don't we
over sample
according why don't we sample according
to these gaussians that we've determined
during the attention mechanism so the
gaussians of course are
uh
summed up over all the attention heads
and over all the sequences in
so sorry all over all the tokens in the
current sequence that you're looking at
because all of these things attend to
the same past
if we sum up all these gaussians over
these things
then we should get an idea of where most
of the attention went and where no
attention went and the idea of sticky
memories is simply let's over sample the
regions
where
a lot of attention went so maybe a lot
of attention went to this bump right
here so we over sample that and maybe
not much attention went to this region
right here so we don't sample anything
like this
then once we
have sampled we spread these things out
i guess equally we could and then we
interpolate
again and that's how we keep the more
important things in memory uh more
accurately
now again this is all heuristics and
this is a bit what my criticism here is
as well all of these
things you know in an lstm it's at least
learned like how to compress the past um
and how to to read it how to use the
past which memories to keep and so on
all of all of this
is
learned right the lstm all the gates are
learned and so on the the waiting
functions now that's also the culprit in
an lstm because you have to back
propagate through time and that's just
not possible for very long sequences so
that's a bit of the lstms downfall as
well whereas here
we don't have to backprop through time
because everything is a heuristic
however everything being a heuristic
it's you know like
how do we know
okay maybe it works but you know i'd
rather
i'd rather not use just heuristics for
doing that kind of stuff
um
yeah
but i guess there's room for improvement
so here they detail that yeah they
smooth the they smooth the signal with a
cnn before they do the multivariate
ridge regression and so on there is a
regularization where they regularize the
variance of the
gaussian that they
predict
um yeah these are details so the
ultimate loss has the training loss plus
the kl divergence maybe they did that
after
they just saw the model simply wants to
attend to everything
um all the time
i don't know
but then they evaluate the model on
various tasks such as this sorting task
and i have to say they construct the
tasks fairly cleverly
by making sure the model can't like use
simple strategies to solve it and what
they see is that
things like the transformer xl which
tries to have some sort of a long-term
memory but not doesn't do it
really like doesn't
i've made a paper on transformer excel
sorry a video so if you're interested in
that you can read it and also this this
compressive transformer seems to be a
little bit what the inf deformer is but
without going via this continuous signal
though the compressive transformer seems
to be a transformer that always tries to
sort of compress the past into fixed
size um memory if i understand it
correctly and generally they find
that their model is
relatively on par with the compressive
transformer outperforming it a little
bit
now this being machine learning and so
on
i would not
i would not be confident
that there is a difference between the
two model or which one is actually
better just from these results in their
results they are better
and when they add the sticky memories
they are even better
which i guess makes sense but again take
that with a grain of salt they do
analyses on what
which parts of the long-term memory this
continuous attention goes to
and in general this seems pretty
reasonable if you look at
um
kind of
you know these
where in these long texts where the
tension goes to like apparently here the
the ground truth is
um
you too
as i guess the answer of a question or
oh no here i guess this is masked out
maybe
and the attention
i'm not exactly sure where it's trying
to predict you to maybe it's mask
language modeling or some sort of
question answering
however it seems to be reasonable
oh there's a helicopter
it seems to be reasonable
at least in this one example they show
so they do
ma sorry not mask language modeling
actual language modeling or against
something like gpt2
and
they outperform that
and they do some more analysis so again
i don't want to go too deep into the
experimental results right here because
again with lots of engineering choices
it seems to be
um
you know
like it's tricky to make sense of small
differences between models what i would
go for is the general trends and the
general trends are are okay
you know i don't know if the code's out
i haven't seen any code if it is out
give it a try i guess otherwise you know
wait for about 30 minutes until lucid
rains has an implementation available
and with that i'll see you next time
bye-bye